Testosterone is the quintessential male hormone,
and it supposedly makes men more manly, right?
Sure, but females have testosterone too.
What do they do with it?
Testosterone is a sex hormone produced in
the adrenal glands, ovaries and testes.
We commonly associate it with men, as it's
necessary for the production of sperm, but,
according to the journal Maturitas it's the
most abundant sex steroid in women throughout
their lifespan.
In cisgender populations, men have 10 times
MORE testosterone in their body than women,
pushing around 4 to 10mg of the hormone per
day through their bloodstreams.
Testosterone is recognized by the general
population but not well understood, and even
scientists haven't mastered it yet.
Those commercials calling for people with
"low T" to talk to their doctors are crazytown!
According to the British Medical Journal only
0.1 percent of men in their forties have low-T.
So why do people care?
Because we think of it as the hormone for
masculinity.
High testosterone is equated with manliness
and mating success -- though interestingly
it's not associated with actual attractiveness.
In one study testing testosterone on female
behavior, women who only believed they'd received
it behaved more aggressively toward other
women.
Most people learned in sex ed that, testosterone
production kicks in during male puberty when
the pituitary gland at the base of the brain
begins releasing luteinizing hormone, or LH;
and follicle-stimulating hormone FSH -- together
they tell the testes to make testosterone
causing development of the penis and testes,
larger muscles, deeper voices, increased height,
and so on.
But in females, 50 percent of their T comes
from their ovaries and adrenal gland throughout
their lives; the rest is naturally converted
from base androgens to testosterone elsewhere
in the body as needed.
Androgens are sort of like the building blocks
of hormones like estrogen and testosterone.
Testosterone is the skeleton key to SO MUCH
in our bodies, and the levels in each and
every person varies.
Testosterone naturally fluctuates throughout
the day, and over our lifetimes.
Levels usually peak in the morning and drop
throughout the day.
In men they peak during puberty, lowering
by 1-2 percent a year after 40, but, female
testosterone production is less well understood
overall; which can cause all sorts of issues.
It seems to help grow healthy bones, but upping
intake can cause blood clots, cancers and
other deadly issues in all humans.
Successful athletes often have more testosterone,
with some women with the highest natural levels
topping men with the lowest natural levels.
A single study found 13.7 percent of women
found testosterone levels higher than the
female average in athletes, and when the International
Olympic Committee tested the female athletic
population of the 2011 Daegu, South Korea
World Championships they found some women
(1.5 to 4.7 percent) at the lowest MALE levels;
while 1.8 percent of the men were within the
typical female range!
As women enter menopause, testosterone production
halts, perhaps to lower libido, but we don’t
really know why.
Female testosterone has been connected with
female body shape, fertility and physical
changes, athletic abilities, making women
nicer to others to gain social standing...
it's even been associated with ladies crying
to release it.
Another study found women taking testosterone
were more opinionated and less productive
while in groups -- focusing more on themselves,
and yet another study found testosterone boosted
lady libidoooo -- but study participants were
also on antidepressants.
So again, testosterone isn't well understood;
and even though we know more about it with
men, we're still kind of bumbling.
There's not even a strong connection between
testosterone and physical violence; but if
you ask the average person they'd say there
is.
What we do know, is testosterone prepares
the body to respond to competition, sexuality,
and challenges to social status -- but outside
of that, science gets nebulous.
Ultimately, there doesn't seem to be an exact
number that's right for everyone.
Do you have a science question?
Want to know about something?
Tell us!